whoa it's calling roddy welcome back
and licorice was a good move thanks for
the tip eric
my pleasure yeah it's a nice kind of
naturally sweet
tea if you if you have a sweet tooth
you'll like the tea
thanks for the five dollars that will
pay for some more egyptian licorice
i was actually i was sent like a bunch
of boxes of egyptian licorice
so i'll be sent i'll be set for uh for
several months
also things ruzilla any cool openings
using one b4
that was good timing haven't played the
orangutan in a while
i mean when you ask that question
b4 is opening
i guess the idea is just to to get this
bishop
on the nice diagonal
[Music]
um
i don't play this too often i think i'll
kind of treat it like a
nimzo larsen except my pawns on b4
so it's controlling a little bit more
space
maybe what i'll do i'll play bishop e2
and go for g4 g5
i'm trying to justify the bishop aligned
with box things
oh some people are still engaging with
the notification
that's nice okay so if i play this
let's do it i'm being very
ambitious with the g pawn hey g5 on move
six
this calls for some g5 emotes
oh you got jess i know what you got jess
is referring to
ah my pawn my beautiful pawn
but blacks and knights the knight is
more beautiful than the pawn
that was nice
hey it was kind of an opening trap
i hope that satisfies the question from
ruzilla
not sure how how common that trap would
be
but the play the play was pretty natural
from black
like 95 was natural and
that's why you got to be careful putting
your pieces on loose squares
okay let's go for the attack
oh can we get a little stafford action
tonight
yeah i've um i've been black a few games
i played sicilian
i played scandi so maybe it's time for
stafford
but first things first i have to take
care of business here
okay so stafford and king's indian
attack
a couple couple openings being requested
so maybe just a friendly request
if you play me as white you should go
into a stafford
you'll make me happy it's also a
guaranteed advantage for white too
okay now things are looking very good
here
only legal move um my mating
it's close to mate
dad's really close to mate
okay a lot of pieces attacking
oh
there's some tension between the bishops
i guess i'm not meeting and like the
bishops are getting traded too
which is kind of unfortunate
i'll leave the bishop there and just
keep developing
the knights want to get into play
ocawa has never caught an eric rosen's
stream
well welcome welcome to twitch
let me know how you found the stream
probably through youtube
or maybe through that one like newspaper
directory
you should run a newspaper ad
or a twitch channel
[Music]
wait are our newspapers even still
printed not sure
sack my queen the queen is enjoying its
life
i would rather not be sacrificed
wants to work together with the knights
a lot of like checking potential
[Music]
hmm
i think i'll start with this preventing
the king from running away
there's two legal moves here there's
this or this
if rook five i fork so black should
probably play king
e5
oh
opponents cooperating oh it's made in
one
i scout using f4 rook f4 takes king f6
but this is kind of aesthetic
it's really aesthetic the most important
pieces are lined up on the e-file
oh thanks ruzilla yeah thanks for
inspiring me
to play such a cool opening discovered a
new trap in the
in the orangutan
that was a dovetail mate hmm
wait what's the tail this is a tail or
no this isn't
like i don't know i lasted a bit longer
than i hoped anyway though gg
oh gg oh thank you christian diane
yeah this name looked familiar d-o-c
de angel so i can quickly share
if you do encounter the polish hello
eric
aka the ringer team to support fine
chess entertainers like yourself
oh thanks so much hgc dte
subbing for six months really appreciate
that
so if you encounter orangutan's black
i'm gonna recommend a bit of opening
preparation
but all you need to know is three moves
if you know three moves
you'll you'll meet the orangutan with
a grand master level preparation
so the three moves are this this and
this
you just take the pawn most players play
bishop b2
you take the pawn and you play this
and this is this is basically the extent
of my preparation
against b4 and the idea even though you
traded a center pawn for wing pawn
which is usually a good trade for
whoever lost the wing pawn
um it's still nice for black because you
accelerate development you castle
you're going to get initiative on the
bishop
maybe if some knight c6 move you're
going to gain space with these pawns
uh very often this bishop can come back
i'd probably recommend d5 c5 and then
knight c6
in conjunction with castling um
eventually white's going to have to move
this bishop and it's going to slow down
the kingside environment
oh no your bits
well thanks for the 500 bits about six
bobcats
and jimberwood today i had a chess class
and we
oh you studied you studied rosen's
gambit
but which gamut is that
i hope that's like a non-dubious gambit
of some sort also think you mashed px
i know for a lot of players b4 is not
the top of
like opening study but it's nice
like if you do encounter it to have
something in mind